Warning, this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children. Viewer discretion is advised.
James dresses as a woman
and JC dress as a man and that happened
numerous times throughout the show
in Pokemon.
Yeah,
in Pokemon. Now, I watched this and I
related to this 100%. because I was a ad
adolescent
girl but I didn't believe I was a girl
thought I was a boy. Okay. So here I am
adolescent boy constantly searching for
recognition and acceptance and I wanted
to become
powerful and I say powerful I mean I
wanted to become known, respected and
loved.
Welcome to today's LED live. It seems
like we can't get enough of this anime
topic. People ask questions all the
time. So, I want to welcome to you the
show today, Daisy. Welcome to the show.
She is an artist from South Africa that
is uh quite a talented artist. She's got
a testimony that talks a little bit
about how anime really messed with her
uh and and sort of led her down a
different path. So, give us give us just
real quick a real background of sort of
your involvement with anime. You were
just an avid watcher. I mean, I know you
can draw it, but
Well, I got introduced to it when I was
studying fine art. Every artist loves a
good anime cuz of the style. And I had a
friend actually that studied with me.
She was just a genius in drawing out of
her head any character she can come up
with. I was so jealous. But and and that
just intrigued me more and more and I
said, "Well, where do you get these
ideas?" And she showed me all this anime
of all sorts and kind. But there were
two specific ones that I kept on wanting
more of from her cuz she had like a
whole series of it. and we're going to
be touching a bit on that as well.
What age were you when you were
introduced to anime?
H I was 21.
Okay.
So, what what's really the deep
fascination with anime? I mean, it's
it's not just like a cartoon. I mean,
when people get into the series, they
really get into it. Is it just because
there's so many of them? I mean, what's
what what's the draw that like people
are like, you're either a fanatic or
they just absolutely like go bonkers
over it. Why does it do that?
Well, I actually I'm going to go a bit
into that as well as to the why. Um, but
the one thing I want to start off by
saying is it's not just a show. M
you know when people watch anime and you
tell them they would watch your videos
about anime and then some might say it's
not it's just a show but I can honestly
from experience say it's not just a show
it's not innocent viewing it had such a
tremendous impact
on me as a person and on my mental
health believe it or not and I actually
titled this topic that anime gave Satan
Access to my heart.
Oh wow. That's a
good title.
That's a good title.
I'm going to explain.
Yeah. I'm I I'm excited to get into
this.
But first, before I go really deep, I I
need to explain something as well that
there's different kinds of anime. I
don't know if you've heard of the
different kinds. There's like six
specific ones that I'm referring to. So,
we're just going to run through them a
little bit and then some of the ones
that really impacted me and how it
impacted me um in such a I I want to say
traumatic way.
It's almost like the stuff just kind of
gets in your head. I remember when we
were putting together this this project
on anime and and it seemed like when we
went home, I don't know about your
experience, but I mean we we edited this
thing over a year and we had to float
through a ton of different anime um you
know adding it together and then sort of
trying to digest it and understand it
and it stuck with me. I mean it was out
of everything I've actually picked apart
or analyzed it was different than the
other stuff. And I'll say out of all the
years that we've put this stuff
together, we've gotten comments and
things uh testimonies from people and
we've never heard anybody say, "My child
seems possessed because they love
Superman." But when we started talking
about anime, we got I I can think of
right now at least three or four
concerned mothers that said, "My child
seems possessed. They love anime. They
have this stuff all over their walls,
DVDs everywhere, and when I look at
them, it's not my daughter anymore.
Like, she's not there anymore. And we've
never seen comments like that. It's
satanic as these comics and stuff that
we put out that we expose and Disney and
all that. We've never heard testimonies
like that. So, there's something even
more dark and sinister about anime and
we're trying to get to the bottom of it.
It's like it's spiritual.
Yeah. And and I and I mean that in like
sort of a bad way, you know what I mean?
Like people that think spiritual, oh
that must mean about God. And it's like
no, this is like supernaturally
like spiritualistic
in in nature. And I think that like you
said, he got you gave Satan access to
your heart. That's what this is doing.
It's like opening up yourself, your
mind, your heart, your whatever you want
to want to call it. And and I think
there's a lot of demonic
involvement in this particular genre,
attachments to it. Demonic attachments
to the anime.
It's more than just demonic. There's a
lot more
the let's let's start with the first
type and that's more focused on the the
little little kids. So on my on my first
slide, you'll see there's like different
types of manga. The first one is called
the Kumudu manga. Now, it's a comic book
for children similar to Pokemon or Dory
Dormon. I don't know if
you see pronunciations is going to get
me,
but yeah. So, it's more focused on those
kind of age groups. Um, now I gave here
a list of the top 15 manga in that age
group, but you can just see there's a
whole list, but I'm just going to focus
on two types
because those two
were were the ones that I watched all
the time and just couldn't get enough of
it.
I just want to make sure we clarify
stuff in case somebody's like a
concerned parent. They're they're just
typing in dangers of anime and this
video pops up. What is manga?
Manga is a type of Japanese style
specific. It's manga specifically
focused on the style. So it's very
recognizable
and it it also comes along with like a
magazine, right? I mean it's like a
comic book and so it's not just the
video. There's like deep deep like sort
of comic books like people read and they
get like the story. It's got canon and
all this background and it's really
deep. Yeah.
Right.
Right. I'm going to give what they say
Kamudo manga is their own personal
description. And on slide one you'll see
kamudo muk is one of the most popular
genres. It literally literally means
intended for children. So under it comes
the children's anime. The series usually
concentrates on giving moralistic
lessons often teaching kids about
staying on the right path.
See they got to win your confidence
early on in life and like oh this is
good for you. They feed you the good
stuff to give you the dark stuff down
the road.
Exactly. But this is this is what really
blows my mind. So, I'm going to give two
examples of what they uh of these
moralistic
lessons and the putting the kids on the
right path. And when I saw this, I was
just
so shocked that they would actually put
that with this genre. And they keep on
saying continuing they are the best
instruments to keep the children at bay
from watching things outside parental
guidance and unfit for their age.
Children's anime is more simple with
episodic plots.
Wow. It's like there even like some
thought and intentionality with like
trying to instill some sort of moral
compass in the kids.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. on on my second
slide there there's this kongjiki noash
bell
this is one specific episode and the
genre is adventure comedy and
supernatural the description of this it
says in this children anime Takamina
Kiaru is a depressed junior high school
student who thinks he's too smart for
school
his I don't care about the world
attitude disappoints his mother. On his
14th birthday, a small naked child
crashes through his window. This kid's
name was Gash Ba and his goal was to be
a mentor for Q Marorrow at the request
of Kumaro's distant father. Okay, so
this naked child is to be a mentor for
this depressed high school kid.
basically what what he's saying. But
this key or tomorrow,
he must help discover the secrets behind
Gash Bell's amnesia. So the kid even has
amnesia
um of his past with only a red book as
as a clue. But Karo soon realizes that
Gashbell is a demon. So this demon
is giving is mentoring this high school
depressed child.
Okay.
Wow.
And Gash is also embroiled in an intense
fight to see who is the ruler of the
demon world armed with the power of the
red book.
Wow. I mean it's shocking to even just
hear or read the description. And this
came from them. This is their own
description of what the show's about.
Wow. See, see this is what this is what
sets this aside. Like we we're talking
about this is different.
When has any other cartoon I mean yes
there's some dark themes and you know if
you look at Pinocchio and stuff there's
some really twisted and messed up things
in those days.
But this is a demon
coming in as a naked baby trying to
teach this boy who's the best demon.
Yeah.
I mean that's a that's a summarization
right there. That's crazy. It's almost
like Peter Pan, but not hidden.
Pan is a demon that comes to the window
and come on and all this, but
we at least hide it in America.
Now it's like, oh, this a demon. He's my
guide.
Oh, wow. I know. And Pokemon is no
better. But Pokemon, just for those that
don't really know, it's about this boy
he called Ash, and he embarks on
becoming a Pokemon master. Okay. And
then he has his friends that joins him
in this endeavor. But then there's this
team called Team Rocket. They're always
nearby. They're sneaky. And they always
want to steal the powerful Pokemon from
other people. So Team Rocket doesn't
collect their own Pokemon. They steal
from others.
Team Rocket, blast off at the speed of
light.
Surrender now or prepare to fight.
That's right. But this Team Rocket has a
fascinating
story. JC and James, they James dresses
as a woman
and JC dress as a man. And that happened
numerous times throughout the show.
In Pokemon?
Yeah.
In Pokemon.
And how long ago was Pokemon out?
Because I mean I remember this from
seemed like when I was a kid.
Has this been around for a while? It has
been for as far as I know I only got
introduced to it when I was in primary
school and that was back in the 90s.
Yeah.
Wow. You know people do not take a look
at the the sort of train linkage between
where we are today in our society. We
have cross-dressing people. We have
people that are gender um fluid. We
have, you know, some of these ideas that
we go when we were kids, we would have
never thought that was imaginable,
right?
But now you start to look back at the at
the um the cartoons that people were
watching, this pretty common one.
Um and you go, "Oh yeah, they've been
planting that seed for years and we are
now living in the day and age where that
seed has grown into a fruition and we're
seeing the fruit of this."
So Pokemon came out in 1996.
Wow. That was my senior year of high
school. Uh
well, for me, I I couldn't get enough of
Pokémon. And what I didn't realize back
then is when I was in primary school at
that age, that was a crucial age for me
because I I believed that I was a boy in
a woman's body. So, I looked like a boy.
I act like a boy. I even talked like a
boy. And people were confused whether I
was a girl or a boy. So they would ask
me straight up, sorry, what are you boy
or girl? Or they would ask my mother and
uh so so most of my primary school
that's what I had to deal with. And just
looking at Team Rocket, it's like almost
they taught me that it's okay to
identify as a boy. It's okay. In fact,
they make it look cool. So
right,
you know what? It shouldn't be a problem
then. So already then things anime had
that influence on me subconsciously
telling me that it's okay for a girl to
be a boy.
And and pictures are worth a thousand
words.
Yeah.
I mean we're talking how many pictures
of this you're just displaying six of
them right here are are burned into your
memory pool. And then, you know, most of
most of what we do all day long is we're
operating out of the subconscious.
Things that things that we've input into
the hard drive and then in our adult
life, we're wondering, why do I feel
like dressing like the opposite gender?
It's like, wow, look at all the training
that's gone into that. So, while we're
on this topic, Sailor Moon was doing
this stuff, too. Sailor Moon's been out
for a long time, and there was like a
boy band on the show called Sailor
Starlights. Mhm.
They did the same thing. They're like
these guys from outer space, but when
they would come to Earth and perform,
suddenly they're women like dressed very
seductive bra and panties and stuff.
[Music]
[Applause]
same thing. Like it's just so confusing
to a kid. This SA S Sailor Moon and
Pokemon are targeted towards children.
Yep. Yep. I mean, they sell I you you
you generally don't see adults wearing
Pokemon backpacks.
No,
I see kids all the time wearing Pokemon
stuff.
And Sailor Moon came out in 1994. So,
two years before Pokemon, but that like
early 90s, early to mid 90s, like this
is being hammered into kids' minds. And
now we look at that generation.
I mean, when you're a young kid in the
'9s, they're the ones who are the young
adults now who are struggling with this.
Yeah.
And this is such a huge topic, the whole
transgenderism and
Yeah.
Yeah. And there's no link.
Yeah. Well, people people I mean, just
just consider what's happening right
here. I was born this way. Really? Or
were you born that way? Or were you
programmed that way? Like like where did
you spend all this time? Because we know
that when you read and digest things, if
you grow up in a Christian church and
you read all the little stories and and
all that, it does have an impact on your
life. You chances are you're going to
identify as Christian down the road,
right? So, if you're identifying with
all this worldliness and these things
that they're putting in these cartoons
that are designed for young kids, you've
written that program that's in their
mind.
Exactly. And remember the description
for this manga? Sorry.
It says it's one of the most popular
genres, but remember it also said it
teaches the kids moralistic lessons
and teach them about staying on the
right path.
Wow.
This is the description for these now.
Pokemon.
Yeah.
Gender confusion. And then you have
Dragon Ball Z. I didn't put Dragon Ball
in my presentation because you guys
already have this
big episode on them already. And there's
a lot of sexualization in there as well.
Messed up stuff. I mean, pedophilia, all
kinds of weird.
And people will try to say that Dragon
Ball is not for kids, but yet you go to
Walmart in the kids section, whether
it's clothing or toys, and you're going
to see Dragon Ball. So, don't tell me
it's not targeted towards children.
Yeah. And I've seen the children wearing
the backpacks and the school pencils and
everything of Dragon Ball.
Yeah. Yeah. That's where words are
cheap, but they say that it's for not
for children. Yeah. But words don't, you
know, it's like actions speak louder
than words.
The the next manga type is called
shownen. Shonen manga. And it's
addressed to teenagers
that still in their developmental
stage. Mhm.
So, shownen manga, my favorite shownen
manga, it's actually mentioned here.
It's Naruto, one that had a tremendous
impact in my life.
See, he's a he's a boy. It says Naruto
is a Japanese manga series. It's about
an adolescent ninja who constantly
searches for recognition and dreams to
become the Hokag. Now, Hokag is one of
the most powerful in the villages.
There's different villages and the hug
is like the powerful one. So he wanted
to become that the ninja in his village
who is acknowledged as the leader and
the strongest of all. So this was his
goal. Now I watched this and I related
to this 100%.
Because I was adolescent
girl but I didn't believe I was a girl
thought I was a boy. Okay. So here I am
adolescent boy constantly searching for
recognition and acceptance and I wanted
to become
powerful and I say powerful I mean I
wanted to become known respected and
loved. So I immediately put myself in
this kid's shoes. But Satan taught me
life lessons in this manga. This is just
a few images I found. There's one of him
as his little boy. Looks innocent, but
further on in his life, you discover
that he has a demon in him that was
sealed. And he eventually embraces that
demon. We learn that the demon is called
Karuma. It's a nine-tailed fox and it's
one of the most powerful of the all the
other demons because in this story there
are nine demons and he was the most
powerful. It says uh Kuruma more
commonly known as the nine tales was one
of the ninetailed beasts. Centuries of
being regarded as a mindless monster and
sought after as a tool for war caused
Karuma to hate humans. So people just
basically use them for their own
agendas.
After being sealed into Naruto, going to
explain how he was sealed, uh, Karuma
attempts to maintain
its cynical perspective about the world.
But with Naruto's insistence on treating
it with respect, the fox overturns its
hatred and willingness
and willingly strives to use its power
for the world's salvation.
Karuma had a great deal of brute force.
It even says repeatedly able to raise
tsunamis and flatten mountains with just
a single swipe of his tail. So, now we
got a little introduction of Kuruma, the
ninetailed fox. It's a demon
and it causes destruction.
A demon that's the savior of the world
though. It says,
so he's saving the world by destroying
it.
Yeah.
He was first used by people for their
own agenda to destroy the world. But
when he was in Naruto, he now became a
savior of the world.
Wow. So a demon is destructive unless
he's possessing a human.
Yep.
Then you can be the savior of the world.
So that what is that what what kind of
lesson is that telling the viewer? Oh,
if I let a demon come in me, it can give
me the power to be the savior of the
world.
Yep. And literally that's what Satan is
claiming he's going to do is save the
world.
It it gets creepier. So Karuma, the tail
beast, he first came into being. Now
this is the when he came into being
right. So he was created he was created
by Hagurumo Utsutuki.
So he was a he was a sage okay he was
really powerful and he used the creation
of all things technique to divide the 10
tales. So there was 10 10 demon 10 of
them. There was a creator and then the
nine demons. Okay. The sage explained to
the youngtailed beast that a link exists
between them despite their separation.
He also fortold of a day when they would
be brought together again though not as
they were and that at that time someone
would emerge to show them what true
power is. Now in this anime before his
death uh Hagarumo this stage he sent
Kurumo the most powerful one he sent
them to uh uh
to build a temple for it. Okay so that
he can live there away from humans away
for humans to use him. But of course all
the shinobi they the shinobi or the
villagers that's what you call it. But
they thought now this thing is too
powerful. We want it. We're going to use
it. And uh uh if if they they did it
they captured him and they sealed him in
a human host. That human host is called
a ginuriki.
I remember it so well. Ginuriki.
And that's where Naruto comes in because
he was a genturiki for Karuma, the
ninetailed beast.
H.
Now what I what's what's interesting
about these beasts is they would leak
their chakra their powers into the host
the genturiki making them more powerful
up until the point where whatever powers
that its host has it gets amplified two
threefold.
So Naruto he didn't realize as a child
he didn't realize it but the demon
started leaking powers into him and he
started to embrace those powers and
realize that hey these powers can make
me strong and then people will accept me
and people will respect me. So, Satan is
teaching me that he can make me strong
and powerful if I allow him in my life.
Wow.
This is the this is the subconscious
teaching that I got from Naruto. I
didn't know it at first.
And this is not just like one episode. I
mean, how many episodes of Naruto are
there? I mean ballpark
a lot like we're talking like in the
Are you serious?
So So I mean you think about this like I
think this is also another reason why it
is so powerful to people because it's
not like just watching one movie or
maybe a trilogy. Okay, maybe there's
three hours of this particular story.
We're talking there's months and months
and months of of content here and then
spread out over years of time that
people like grow up and change with
these characters. I think that's what's
so powerful about it.
I wanted to kind of touch back on the
the gender bending LGBTQ issue thing. I
looked it up because I I do see a lot of
these fans when we go to the conventions
and things like that that seem like
they're open, you know, to that
lifestyle. And so this is
comicsbeat.com.
This is nothing to do with Christianity
at all. This was actually an article
from 2017
and it says, "Report 50% of anime fans
are now open to Yaoi themes." Y a oi and
I'm like okay I'm not sure what that
means but it this report says 50% of
anime fans are now open to yay yaomi
theme themes. So I looked up what is yay
yaoi and it says yayoi is defined as
commercial and fan created media that
thematically focuses on the romantic
love between two men often in sexually
explicit and in way. So this was not a
Christian report and this was 2017
saying that half of anime fans are now
like open to to wanting to to desiring
to watch and read
or to explore
openly gay men sexual story lines. H
notice the transition cuz it started
subtly in the Kamura manga even at the
children the specifically targeted
children and then moving forward next to
teenagers you have the same thing and so
forth and so forth where the very last
type of anime is hardcore porn
hand
explicit
yeah yeah because porn porn benzu your
mind. We kind of discussed this a couple
times on on on a few different shows.
Um, sexuality that this beautiful gift
that God gave us is really the most
ultimate others focused activity that
you could do, right? So, when you're in
a man, woman, married relationship,
right, and you're giving pleasure to
somebody else and you both are doing
that, you know what I mean? That's like
that's like the ultimate uh
demonstration of love. How can I give
you this burst of of of pleasurable
feelings?
But but the devil's twisted that and
he's now made it like such a selfish
act. We're either having sex with
ourselves or we're having sex because we
just want to irrespective of their age
or does this harm them or is it wrong?
Is it not in a marriage, you know,
paying for it?
Yeah. So, so what you really don't
realize is when you have sex outside of
the marriage, you're having sex with
someone's wife. M
and so look at what that does to your
spirituality because true religious
Christ centered Christianity is love
your neighbor as yourself and love God
with all your mind, your heart, your
soul, right? And so now this has just
turned into this like expression of
selfishness and that in itself is what
bends your spiritual mind. No,
it's interesting you said that because
with Naruto, I created a reality in my
mind where Naruto's life was my life.
His failures were my failures. His
victories were my victories. So, I lived
in the anime as if that was my life and
uh my reality. Okay? And reality itself
to me was not real.
My reality
was Naruto.
That's what happened in my mind. Now the
nine tailed demons in Naruto, my demon
without knowing it was Satan. See, I
already allowed Satan in my life because
he promised he'll give me strength.
He'll make me powerful. He'll make me
love and respected and all I have to do
is follow his guidance and he can give
me the power like the ninetail fox gave
Naruto power so I can basically be
successful with him in my life. But of
course none of that happened. The truth
he put the truth his truth that he put
it in my mind subconsciously
he told me was that I can never be like
that. See I keep watching it. I live
that life in anime but in reality that
can never happen. So he basically taught
me that in reality that I am worthless,
useless and hated because I'm different.
And the more I watched, the more it fed
my depression and the toxic beliefs of
myself. And to escape those feelings, I
would watch more of what I want to be
like. And it's like an ongoing cycle of
watching what I want to be like and
realizing more that I can never be like
that. Building these false perception of
myself, worthless, useless, hated
because I was different.
This is what happened. watching Naruto.
That is so powerful because it just
think of what's happening on the
opposite end of this spectrum. You're
watching a show that somehow you're
living vicariously through. You're
looking through their eyes and then
you're you're attaining their attributes
and and basically modeling your life
after them. But he's dangling the
carrot. Satan's dangling the carrot so
far away from you that it's like becomes
this insatiable addiction, but it's a
downward spiral.
Look at what Jesus offers.
If you focus on Jesus and you read the
stories of Jesus, you take on the
character of Jesus and you take on what
his life is like and his life isn't a
lie. He's actually promised you that the
more you focus on it, the more you're
going to get it. Look at this. Absolute
100% opposite end of the spectrum
is happening.
Counterfeit.
That's not where it ended.
Wow.
My my the other anime
kind of a little bit similar as Bleach.
I don't know if you've heard about
Bleach before.
Yeah. Yes. I don't know much about it.
I've heard it. I know what it is, but I
haven't heard much about the story line.
Well,
it's basically the main character is
Ichigo Kurusaki. He's a teenager and he
can see ghosts. Okay. A talent allowing
him to meet supernatural human Rukia.
So, this is where his journey stand.
Rukia is a soul reaper. Okay. She came
to kill a soul reaper to kill a hollow.
Now, hollows are something that's
dead, but not really. It's like a in
between. And if you look at the images
on slide eight, Ichigo and two hollows,
you'll get an idea of what the hollows
look like.
Oh, yeah.
So, those hollows,
they come to existence when they died.
But when they die as a human, the soul
reaper would come and set them free and
send him to soul society which is like a
heaven. Okay? But if they don't set them
free, they turn into a hollow. And a
hollow can kill humans and other ghosts.
So these soul reapers, they sent to kill
all these hollowos.
I don't know if you followed me on that.
I do. And and I'm just looking at these
images going, does this look friendly?
Like
is anybody like and and and I I truly
believe in that statement. By beholding,
you become changed.
When you stare at these images which are
utterly demonic,
I mean, those are dark, demonic, evil,
sinister. Those things look like they
want to kill you and everybody else in
the room. And it's like, why are we
giving these things our time?
Bleach is a popular a popular anime.
So, I'm I'm looking right now. I just
looked. It said um I said, "What age is
anime Bleach for?" This is This is from
Common Sense Media, which I I thought
was more conservative, you know, but it
says a little bit of swearing and
violence, but overall, not as much as
modern media, creates a 12 and up. This
that we're looking at demonic possession
is for 12y olds. Wow,
it is shocking. And I I was attracted to
this because like Ichigo, he was
insignificant at first until this soul
reaper visited him and this soul reaper
Rukia gave him some of her power. So now
he became a soul reaper.
Oh no.
[Applause]
Soulreaper
and my name is
Ichigo Kurasaki.
[Music]
[Applause]
How could this have happened?
I meant to give him only half of my
powers, but somehow he's taken nearly
all of it.
This ends now.
What kind of being is he?
I've never seen a human with spirit
energy this strong. That's what was
jamming my senses before.
I have never heard of a human with
enough strength to break the keto on his
own.
And I have never seen a soul reaper
wield such a huge zhateau.
[Music]
You will pay the price for hurting my
family, you hollow skunk. Feel the wrath
of my plague.
[Music]
And so his mission now was to kill
hollows.
Now this is something I want to mention
with soul society
you get the captains and you get
lieutenants right in that image
the captains are like unbeatable there's
no way you can fight a captain and
actually win and then the lieutenants
serve just under it so Ichigo was at
that stage where he couldn't beat the
lieutenants or the captains even if he
wants to okay but there came a stage age
where Ichigo
embraced
hollow powers
so that he can be powerful enough to
defeat
strengths of lieutenants and captains.
Now these lieutenants and captains they
stayed in soul society
heaven right but none of those are
actually pure in character all of them
oh let me say 90% of them are
narcissistic sadistic
and lustful to some
and the lieutenants are not much
different and this is the heaven and
they save people and send them to
heaven.
I mean,
yeah, they're just perver per perverting
and distorting what even kids' ideas of
heaven are. And if you really don't like
that and you fall in love with Ichigo is
that the person that most people are
kind of paying attention to in Bleach is
like they they're following his story.
They want he's the protagonist
basically.
Yeah.
And in order for him to get the strength
that he needs to fight these guys, he
has to embrace being demonpossessed.
Yeah. So, so If I understand this
correctly, it's like here's a messed up
version of heaven and this guy doesn't
fit in there.
And so he's just decided to just go all
out with houble hockey sticks and
everything else with him.
And that's probably the character that
everybody that watches this is like
wanting to be like.
And who is he? Could it be?
I mean, he was unfit for heaven, right?
And now he's trying to
he's kicked out. Can't be this or that.
Wow. Wow. It's like this just
reincarnated perverted version of the
great controversy between Christ and
Satan. But it's just like instead of
actually these good guys that are
wholesome, righteous, holy, and heaven
is this beautiful bliss, that's what the
Bible describes it as,
they they show you, ah, it's not that
cool of a place anyway. This guy's more
powerful, and he gets to beat both of
them,
you know? And it's it's very very bloody
like they don't even play around with
that. And sometimes it gets sexual and
lustful. Sometimes they don't. You just
see the lustful aspect of it. For me,
why I got attracted to these was Ichigo.
Similar to Naruto, he had to embrace
Satan. If I can say I needed to embrace
Satan if I am going to be popular, if
I'm going to be accepted and respected.
So Bleach and Naruto started that
journey giving Satan access to my heart,
to my life, teaching me
lies of myself.
Wow.
There's a lot of research that has shown
violence mixed with sexuality is
actually really destructive to you. Um,
anybody that's turned into a psycho
killer like Charles Manson, go back and
look at some of his Bundy,
Ted Bundy and some of these guys like
they actually attributed their violence
mixed with porn or porn that turned
violent and that's what bent their minds
and and I think it's because once again
going back to right God created this
beautiful thing called sexuality where
it's you're giving to somebody else,
you're loving somebody else. It's this
it's this human expression of ultimate
pleasure like like I want to please you
and bending that to like I'm killing you
or killing something and it's dying and
I'm getting sexual gratification off of
that.
That's as like opposite end of the
spectrum as as love as as it's just the
sickest form of lust.
Yeah.
I mean even lust is like like pretty
bad. We make vampire movies uh in the US
that that they're always putting like
this kind of like lustful element to it,
right? It's this sort of twisted version
of love, but it's like if you really
consider what's going on here, it's like
you're going to suck their blood, kill
them, and then you love them like you're
you're having some sort of sexual
gratification. So, we have our own form
of that, but not just outright
disgusting like this is. And Ted Bundy,
he was interviewed when he was in prison
and asking him what made him this way,
you know, and he said, "Pornography. If
you don't take porn off the shelves,
you're going to see a lot more people
like me." He was a a serial rapist and a
serial killer. And he said, "Porn did
this to me. You need to get this off the
shelves." And this is something I think
I want to emphasize is the the the the
most damaging u
kinds of pornography. And my again I'm
talking from personal experience uh hard
real personal experience. The most
damaging kinds of pornography are those
that involve violence and sexual
violence because the wedding of those
two forces as as I know only too well
brings about behavior that is just
is just too terrible to describe.
No,
the question and and and the issue is
how this kind of literature contributed
and helped mold and and shape the kinds
of violent behavior
fueled your fantasies. Well, in in the
beginning it fuels this kind of thought
process. Then it at a certain time it's
instrumental in what I would say
crystallizing it making into something
which is almost like a separate entity
inside
and that in at that point you're at the
verge or I was at the verge of acting
out on this on this kind of these kinds
of thoughts. I want really want to
understand that you had gone about as
far as you could go in your own fantasy
life
with printed material
and you made or printed and video or
film
film magazines what have you
and and then there was the urge to take
that little step or big step over to a
physical
event
and it happens it it happened in stages
gradually it doesn't necessarily not to
me at least happen overnight. My
experience with let's say pornography
generally but with pornography that
deals on a violent level with sexuality
um is that
once you become addicted to it and I
look at this as a kind of addiction uh
like other kinds of addiction of
addiction you keep I would keep looking
for more potent more explicit more
graphic kinds of material like an
addiction you keep craving something
which is harder
harder, something which which gives you
a greater uh sense of of excitement
until you reach the point where the
pornography only goes so far. You reach
that jumping off point where you begin
to wonder if if maybe actually doing it
will give you
that which is beyond just reading about
it or looking at it
because it makes you not want to be
others focused. It's like the ultimate
sealing and seeding in of your selfish
character and then you're adding in that
like sick abusive like disgusting you
know
choke murder punch.
Yeah. And then and then associating
pleasurable feelings to that. It's just
as as satanic as you can get.
Yeah. Another aspect of um this specific
bleach is I in my mind I I was a lost
soul. Um I didn't just relate to Ichigo
but those lost soul that needed to be
saved by a soul reaper. I saw myself as
that lost soul and I needed protection
from this cruel world full of hollow
people that doesn't love me. This is
what I learned from bleach in my mind.
So I needed a loving and caring and
nurturing hand in my life and
that is exactly catered to me at that
stage in my life because this was when I
was between 18 and 20 years old. Um I
was looking for that nurturing and that
caring. I was looking for it and I
didn't I didn't get it. I didn't get
what I wanted. And uh I
Satan through this anime manipulated
that need in me with anime. Anime filled
that need for me. Like the more I
watched, the more I in that moment felt
good. In this story, most of the
captains and the lieutenants were all
sadistic, narcissistic,
and I wanted
them to be my savior. I want
subconsciously, I want Satan to save me.
Yeah.
Because those are his characteristics.
He's sadistic. He's a murderer from the
beginning. He's a liar. He doesn't fit
anywhere. He's the one that got cast
out. He wants to kill you. and and he
takes pleasure over that. I mean, it's
like what characteristics does that have
anything to do with Jesus? Nothing.
What's amazing is what you just said
about what bleach did for you. You were
seeking certain things. you you were
going through pain and you need you
wanted love and to be accepted and all
these things and bleach was the thing
that you gravitated towards because in
some way it it gave you it gave you that
and that's the that's what's going on.
Like somebody mentioned this to me
recently. He was like you guys are
talking about these things and showing
what's wrong with them but why are
people watching them? He's saying what
is making those people watch that stuff?
He's saying because they're not getting
some they're not getting the fulfillment
that they're really desiring in their
real life and they're gravitated towards
that and and Satan is just using the
pain of people's lives that this this
world we're living in is full of pain
and trials and all this and we should
all be going towards Christ. That pain
should be pushing us towards Christ, the
only one that can give us the peace that
we're looking for, the joy, the hope.
But Satan keeps putting out all these
distractions that don't look at the
Bible. Don't look at those hypocrites in
church. Look at this awesome anime. And
in the anime is I'm the savior, Satan.
I'm the one. You have to embrace me. You
have to become demonpossessed. And
that's what's going to bring you
fulfillment. And that's what's going to
make you popular and and full of life
and all these things.
And look, it's Satan that is ultimately
creating the problem.
Yeah. I mean, I know he's creating the
problem and the solution.
Exactly. That's why he creates the
problem is he's literally trying to make
a hole in you so that you come to him
and he's like, "Look, I've got what to
fix for you." But like like Daisy just
mentioned, the more that you go to that
without having a real solution, it's
like it presents more of a problem, a
bigger problem, and that gaping hole
feels so void, and it starts to grow so
vast and grand that you just see people
get utterly depressed. That's something
that I have heard when talking about
this subject going around and talking
with young kids all over the country,
all over the world actually that talk
about the more I mean there's like a
literally a direct link. The more anime
they watched, the more depression they
felt.
Yeah.
Would you agree with that?
That's exactly what happened to me.
Postanime depression syndrome pads.
Yeah. So, he's creating these heroes
that are demonpossessed or bisexual or
whatever. And so the viewer is like
that's what I need to do to be to fill
this void.
The depression got bigger because you
are watching a life that you want. The
physical appearance, the strength,
everything. That's what you want. So in
that moment, you watch it to feel like
that. But as soon as it's turned off,
you're depressed because you don't have
it. And when you stop, you get more
depressed. It's like Yeah. And that's
exactly what happened to me. That's such
a huge impact on my mental health.
Wow. I hope parents and young kids that
are watching this right now are
listening to this.
Yeah.
I hope you're listening to this. And I
hope that that more so than being angry
because something that you like is being
attacked. just take a step back and say,
"Is this actually fixing or helping or
am I walking away from watching these
things a better person or do I actually
really feel disgusting?"
Why don't you do a test? Do a Daniel
test.
Put it down for a second and give God a
chance in your life.
No. Why don't you pick up a Bible and as
much time as you would spend with the
anime, why don't you turn around and
just say, "Okay, God, I'm going to give
you a chance and let's spend this time
with you."
And you see, just see, just observe.
Yeah.
Let it speak for itself. You observe.
When you do that and you really truly
honestly pour your heart out to God and
say, "God, I'm feeling uh helpless here.
I I I want to feel more power. I want to
feel whatever like this." Ask God just
like Daisy was searching for that.
No. and see what that does for you. Just
try it.
Don't don't speak against it. Don't
fight against it. Don't kick against it.
Try it.
Yeah. Don't knock it till you try it.
Now, as as the different types of manga
shows from children to teenagers to
young adults, there's a we move to the
next type of anime. It's called Shouju
manga.
Shouju manga is mainly for young girls.
Uh focuses on love and friendship
stories and school girls such as Nana.
That's a anime but so it it focuses on
love and friendships. That's the
description of it. In my side nine
aimed at teen girls and young adult
women. Now here's an example. one
example of sojun manga.
Uh citrus is the name of it. Now I'm
just going to quickly read the
description of this. It says when May
and Yuzu first may meet, it's on
absolutely terrible terms because Yuzu
doesn't dress respectably. Student
council president May treats Yuzi. Now
Yuzi is the one on the right. Uh May
treats Yuzi like she's beneath her while
she barely even willing to talk to her.
She does molest her in public in order
to confiscate her cell phone and
forcibly kisses her without permission.
Yuzi quite reasonably res resents her
for not caring about her consent but
then ultimately decides she likes May.
This happened even though by this point
their parents have gotten married,
making them step sisters.
Oh wow. It's just like it gets more
demented as it goes. It's like first
she's a bully that's molesting you, but
hey, I kind of like her and oh, now her
parents are married and we're step
sisters.
But listen to how how Daisy, you just
read the description of what this is
about. This is about love and teenagers
and blossoming and they're like
molesting unconenting
sisters, stepsisters. This is gross.
Wow.
It's messed up. It's exactly what it is.
Gravitation is about two guys. One is uh
famous, the other one is not. They meet
each other. They start to fall in love
and begin an relationship.
And then hot it gets messed up like
really sadistic hot gimmick. It's about
the character buys a pregnancy test for
a little sister and he's caught by
Rookie, the son of a company president.
They all live in company housing where
the family of the company president has
huge social power. So he has the power
to make her whole family's life
miserable. So he made her his slave. He
had the wealth and the power. So he can
make her his slave.
Lovely story. Yeah.
No, it's focused on young girls love and
friendship,
right?
I mean,
you're a slave.
Come on.
But Right. And then Wolf Girl and the
Black Prince. Now it's about this girl
who starts a new clash. She has no
friends. she just kind of dives into the
first group of people she can talk to uh
who are two girls completely obsessed
with their older boyfriend. So of course
she has to make up a boyfriend. So she
knows them. A picture of this random hot
guy who turns out to be Cooa, one of the
cutest boys at her school who happens to
be in another class.
Now it gets messed up. He agrees to keep
up the ruse as long as she agrees to be
his dog.
Oh man.
Which is pretty much another way of
saying his slave. So he teases her
mercilessly, makes her do things like he
might throw uh if she angers him, he
might throw a stick and be like, "Go
fish.
forchech.
[Music]
I'm going to You're going to have a
Huh?
[Music]
Wow. And
she has to do it or else be ridiculed
and mocked for not having a boyfriend.
So God God made man and gave him
dominion over the animal kingdom. And
Satan just loves to to Oh, really? You
think you're the top of the food chain?
And it's like he's portraying man in
this derogatory. You're you're just an
animal. You're just not even you're not
even human. And I mean, what does that
do to a young young girl's mind? You
know,
it teaches them about relationships
basically is the boy has control over
you and he can do whatever he wants with
you
and you just have to obey.
Mhm.
That's the message I'm getting from that
manga aimed for teenage girls.
Right.
Wow, man.
Right. Yeah. Because an animal is
supposed to obey its master. Yeah.
Yeah.
That's messed up.
Next one is Shining Manganger. Now,
instead of that's more focused on
reserved for students or young adults,
it covers more realistic subjects of
various themes such as Death Note or The
Attack of the Titans.
Now, I love how it says covers more
realistic subjects of various themes,
right?
Death Note.
Yeah, that's realistic. He has a demon
that's telling him like, you know, gives
him the power to write down who he wants
to be killed. And I mean,
we we're starting to notice a pattern
here.
Yeah.
With Satan teaching.
He is a teacher in anime. He's teaching
you what is supposed to be a better
life, the proper life to live. Yeah. I
bought into those lies.
He's such a a better evangelist than
Christians are. And you look at the
majority of the content that gets put
out in the world and it's Disney,
Marvel, anime, and how many people are
consuming that
and we're out here trying to like get a
video out or give a book to somebody.
And
man, it's it's like we're fighting in a
sinking ship.
Yeah.
Trying to trying to win souls. This is
this is what we're competing with is is
you know I mean you think about how many
more people watch this than they do a
sermon or you know a ministry video or
something. We're like this tiny little
ministry in the corner of the internet.
I mean millions and millions of people
are being exposed to this.
Yeah.
Exactly. I was one of those.
We're thankful that you've crossed over.
Yeah.
Join the God's side.
Me too. Me too. coming out of it. I am
so happy and it took only God's power to
get me out of it. I couldn't do it on my
own.
Couldn't it was impossible. The the
second last one, this this got for me
quite messed up. Jose manga.
It is traditionally printed in
uh dedicated manga magazines which often
specialize in a specific sub genre like
drama, romance or pornography. Those
three categories. Now this is now also
the target audience are students
male, female, adult, women uh with adult
challenges in life.
The drama are more realistic stories of
the lives of ordinary women typically
focusing on working women uh powerful
women housewives
may also address social issues such as
aging and dementia. So the drama in just
say is they they
look at the average adult life. So
people watching this, the adults that
watching this can relate to it because
it's talking to them in their situation.
So Satan is already capturing them in
that sense. And now he now that he's
caught you by watching it, now he can
teach you how to live
with those
themes that he's presenting here.
It's it just makes an open book, a open
field for Satan to tell you, all right,
so you're a housewife. Let's look at a
life that you can be can lead at being a
housewife,
right?
And even the romance, I mean, romance is
probably one of there's so many romantic
movies, romantic novels, because so many
people don't know what romance truly is.
So they have these examples that they
watch and the Jose Mangard gives them
sadistic examples of what romance is.
None of it
clear biblical you know romantic
relationship with with you know two
people that are loving each other and
and and you know doing kind things for
each other and you know marriage is is
is not designed necessarily for your
happiness. It's designed for your
holiness. Your marriage makes you makes
you confronted with your selfish self
and you now have this other life that's
part of you and you have to work
together and it and it really for lack
of a better term it curbs your
selfishness.
Yeah.
And what these things do by not giving a
clear picture of what that relationship
should be, it's just planting seeds of
of absolute confusion.
Scotty brought to my attention something
I never even thought about before.
before. I just always thought romance,
you know, chick flicks or whatever. But
he said the majority, if not all, of
romance movies are are leading into some
adulterous relationship. It's always a
man and a woman. They're married or
they're about to get married and she's
like, "He's just not who I thought he
was and he's not romantic or whatever."
And then some guy comes along and you
know, next thing you know, they're in a
car together. You know, Titanic, same
thing. She was supposed to be married to
that guy and she's, you know, getting
drawn naked and in the car with that guy
and then you've got mail. Yeah.
It's like it is notebook. All these
movies are about f the better one comes
along when you're already with someone
else.
Yeah, I know. You hit the nail on the
head right there. And these romance in
this manga, they also teach you
uh different variants of sexual
identities.
It literally teaches you you can be
whatever sexual identity you want to be.
Our world our world's really grappling
with that right now. You know,
and the porn pornography, I mean, I
don't have to say more on that. And that
pornography in this manga, it's it's not
just men and women. It's all those
sexual identities that you learn about
in the romance
that can be portrayed in pornographic
style, not style, pornographic
visuals of all those variant
sexualities. Not between a man, not just
between a man and woman, all of it. How
messed up is that?
I mean I mean I mean you got ones like
Inuasha which is like basically you know
a female falling in love with like a
half beast looking thing.
Yeah, he was half dog half demon. So not
only is he a demon but he's a dog. He's
an animal.
Inuasha. I'm begging you. Please don't
change.
Try what you will, your efforts are in
vain. The human heart he possessed is
locked inside this mirror. He will never
be a half demon again.
Kakome, get away from him. Don't be
killed.
I love you as a half demon, Inuasha. To
be honest, I like you just the way you
are. There's nothing wrong with staying
just the way you are.
[Applause]
[Music]
Inuasha.
I love you. I love you as a half demon.
What's the matter, Enu Yasha? Why the
hesitation?
How can I stop his transformation?
[Laughter]
Free the beast of carnage that lives
inside you. And once you are a full
demon, bring me the flesh of that girl.
New Yasha, you want to stay with me,
don't you?
And they do it in a
it's like they're try this is like them
testing the waters. Okay. Will people
watch beastiality if he comes in the
form of an attractive boy or something
and then next time it'll just be oh girl
falls in love with dog. It won't even
look like because they you know you got
beauty and the beast same kind of thing
like oh the woman she's falling in love
with the beast and Yasha Kagomi is
falling in love with half dog half demon
then in Sailor Moon you know there's
like this little girl that Sailor Moon
thinks her boyfriend's cheating on her
with a grade school girl and it's like
no she's really you know that's another
thing we see like in uh Seven Deadly
Sins this guy is getting drunk and
having sex with a girl. It's clearly
underage, but it's like, "No, she's 600
years old." That's always the defense
that comes at us, like, "No, she's a
thousand years old." And
but she looks like a nine-year-old.
Yeah, it looks like a nine-year-old.
Yeah.
So, there's always this little cover
story to make it okay.
Yeah. We actually have some of those
messed up um um videos that I've never
really never thought about in this
context before. Teen Wolf.
Yeah, exactly. Team Wolf. I I mean, we
have our version of this. I guess this
is just more out in the open with like,
you know, you actually can watch them
engage in some sort of sexual activity.
Think about the movie Big with Tom
Hanks. Yeah.
He made a wish. He's a 13-year-old kid.
He made a wish. The next day, he's a
grown man. And then there's a scene of
him
naked about the Well, he does. He has
sex with a grown woman. A grown woman
has sex with a 13-year-old because it
comes in the form of comedy and his Tom
Hanks and he looks grown but he's
actually 13 years old.
Really perverting what God made
Yeah.
special.
And pure. The last type of manga genre
is hintal manga. That is 100% just
hardcore porn.
Oh.
And it it's actually kind of hard to
get, but
this type of manga is becoming very
popular.
I I I don't think I need to say anything
more on that.
No, but it it does go way more sadistic
and demonic than just male female
relationships.
the it becomes there's not just the sex
part but abuse of
abuse and demonic
that's it
I had watched
abusing a woman is the right way to do
it
yeah when I was into this stuff in my
gothic years there was something called
yatsi doia legend of the overfeiend and
an overfeendi is a demon and basically
demons were entering into the physical
world raping women to create a uh
demonic h a demonic human hybrid race.
And so every episode was graphically
about a demon raping a woman.
So I mean these are the things that are
being put out there. It's not just you
know you can't even justify it as like
well it's two people in a relationship.
It's not.
You know what I I'm not going to name
the anime there. So the previous anime
which is Jose manga uh that I watch some
I can't even remember the name of it but
they taught me that
sex means love. Doesn't matter in what
form it is if you have that lustful
interaction
that is love.
So at that stage in my life I was
looking for love. And I learned that
love is only through physical
interaction,
sexual interactions.
And so I sought that and that is when I
became addicted to pornography
because I was looking for that love and
while watching pornography it gave me
the notion of love and I because I
wanted it. So the more I watched in that
moment the more I felt that need was
filled which is actually wasn't. So when
I stopped watching it I was depressed
because now I compare and I was lonely.
I didn't have anyone. I'm not love
useless worthless everything that Satan
taught me and I believed in myself. Um
so what do I do? I watch more.
Yep. It's a fantasy world without
fulfillment.
And so it's like dangling the carrot.
You're living vicariously through those
people you're engaged in watching.
They're doing this act that that is
this, you know, sort of wonderful
experience that God gave us to be shared
within a marriage context, but you're
not really engaging in it. You know what
I mean? And it's like this weird thing.
So you're tricking the senses. You're
tricking the mind. And it's like a
hijacking of the the natural system that
God designed to bond us together. And
what happens is you get bonded to those
things. That's why pornography is so
hard to get rid of. That's why, you
know, hand tie, I mean, we we went and
interviewed young kids for this. And
remember, a couple of those young
14 years old
14 years old said their very first
introduction into anime was hand tie.
Yeah.
And it was like, well, yeah, it's all
downhill from there. Like, this is what
they're trying to lead you into.
Yeah. And so I I just as a word of
caution, any of you guys that are out
there watching this, I mean I mean this
with all honesty of all like I I've only
looked into this subject because of
research, you're now hearing Daisy give
you a realworld experience of what it
did to her.
So between what we've investigated, what
we've looked at, what we put together, I
mean watch the documentary that we
created. Um, you know, you can you can
get a hold of of that through uh
Vimeo.
Vimeo. You can click the link on the
description up here. We'll put a link to
it. But um it's like man, if you or your
kids or anyone you know is getting
involved in this world, it is a downward
spiral that will eventually lead you
into this particular type of genre. And
then there's there's only darkness from
here. And it just keeps getting worse is
what I hear.
Anime
broke down God's character in me because
what is the one thing we take to heaven?
Our character
and Satan knows this. So he watching
anime my character got formed into his
likeness to Satan's likeness.
Yeah.
Wow. I learned with anime because
there's so much killing, so much blood
that I started to kill people in my
mind.
Oh wow.
That is murder whether you do it
physically or it's in your mind.
I committed murder in my mind
countless times
because that's what Jesus said, right?
If you're angry to the point where you
wish that person didn't exist
at that point, you literally have
virtually murdered them.
They they they they would be wiped off
this planet and I wouldn't feel a lick
of the problem. And and and so, you
know, it's like, yeah, the devil's he's
found this way to sort of make all of
these sinful acts happen in here.
We don't actually have to go out and do
those things. You don't have to even
have sex. All you got to do is watch
other people do it. You don't have to
kill people. All you got to do is watch
other people kill people. You don't have
to be uh necessarily calling out for
demon possession. All you got to do is
watch other people get demonp possessed.
And I guarantee you that's opening port
holes to be demonpossessed.
Daisy, thank you so much for being so
honest with us and sharing. I know
sometimes those those vulnerable moments
are difficult to share, but I I I don't
think your experience is alone. Oh,
I I think if if if there's one thing
that I've learned about this whole anime
and manga and stuff, it's and the most
scary thing to me about it is the
possession aspect.
And and it's beautiful that we serve a
God that's more powerful than any of
this stuff.
I mean, you can spend hours and years
and get to the bottom of the pit and
feel like there's absolutely no way out.
And look at this. God resolves your
probleming
and clears the slate
and sets your feet on a different path.
Amen.
And that is beautiful. I mean, that's
literally the best part of this whole
video.
Yeah. And it's all just our our
surrender to him. God's wanting to help
us, but he will not go against our own
will. He will not go against our own
desires. He's knocking on the door of
our heart. He's hoping that we that we
open the door and let him in. But he
will not force himself in the way Satan
does. Satan will use tricks. He'll use
subliminal messages and all these things
and and put his message in a pretty
little package and then, you know, years
down the road, you're at a terrible
place. But God, if we allow him to come
in, he can get rid of it all.
So true. Daisy, thank you so much once
again for blessing us on this particular
channel. We hope that you guys were
extremely blessed by this as well. This
is a powerful
personal story, personal investment into
this topic and actually the solution on
how to get out of it.
And so if that's your experience,
seriously, I hope and pray that you will
give God a cha a chance. Taste the Lord.
See that he's good. Give him an
opportunity. Hey, say look, God is such
a gentleman. He's saying like if you if
you've tried this, all I'm asking you
for you to do is just take one step
forward. Just one step towards me and uh
and and and let God prove to you that
he's got a better way. He's got a higher
road. He's got a road that won't lead
you into depression. In fact, that road
leads you out of depression. He won't
lead you into addiction. He leads you
out of addiction. So, if that's your
experience, please consider prayerfully
to click on this next video. And uh we
thank you guys for watching. If you know
somebody that's struggling in this area
or or really into anime and they would
be blessed by the show, send it to them.
And uh if this is your first time here,
we welcome you. Like, subscribe. We got
tons of this kind of content. U we've
got cool t-shirts if you go to
lightwear.shop. We got fun shirts that
basically illustrate biblical topics.
And uh there's nothing better than, you
know, don't promote that that that
newest anime that's out that's on every
Walmart t-shirt. Promote God. Amen.
And put your stake in heaven and you
will not be sorry. So, we love you guys.
Thanks for watching. We'll see you on
the next LED live.
[Music]
Do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for? Video Bible Study, or VBS
for short, is a YouTube channel that
answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less. Check out these easy to
understand, comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering?
Make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video Bible study on
YouTube to help you along your journey.
[Music]